heute ist die hannover messe zu ende
gegangen es ging wieder mal um industrie
4.0 um die sogenannte smarte fabrik und
künstliche intelligenz
eröffnet wurde die messe wie immer durch
biologische intelligenz in gestalt von
dr angela merkel die die dort bei der
eröffnung geschenke so emotionslos
entgegen nimmt dass sich mancher roboter
schämen würde
band ist
sehr interessant wollen sie sich selber
wegschmeißen oder sonnig so freut sich
meine frau weihnachten auch immer
künstliche intelligenz ki ein thema das
immer brisanter wird maschinen die
dazulernen die selbstständige
entscheidungen treffen das wirft
natürlich fragen auf auch ethische
fragen welche arbeiten lässt man die
blech kollegen machen denn zb
pflegeroboter eingesetzt werden er
möchte sicherlich niemand dass so eine
kalte roboterhand über das gesicht der
mutter streicht ihr besser so als wenn
ich das machen muss hallo mama ja
wir deutschen müssen habe ich gelesen
aufpassen dass wir nicht den anschluss
verlieren in sachen ki wobei in manchen
bereichen sind wir immer noch weltspitze
wissen sie der medizintechnik flug taxi
solche sachen künstliche intelligenz
reden wir drüber mit einem der
attraktivsten it-spezialisten
ostdeutschlands mit olaf schubert damen
und herren
oder schön dass du da bist
das thema künstliche intelligenz macht
offenbar vielen zeitgenossen angst warum
eigentlich
die frage also ich bin dafür also also
könnte die games am besten gleich jeden
morgen unter den joghurt röhren mit den
künstlichen aromen künstler oder per
zäpfchen rein damit denn viele menschen
haben angst vor künstlicher intelligenz
wenn sie selber mit intelligenz nur ganz
wenig berührung haben eine
durchschnittliche normale intelligenz
quotient liegt ja glaub ich so kurz über
der zimmertemperatur und da kann man ja
jahrelang durch noch so mittlere
verwaltung oder fußball moderator und
jetzt aber jetzt kommt die künstliche
intelligenz um die ecke
das merkt man wenn einen der laptop so
art wenig anguckt und alles ist
intelligenter kühlschrank was weiß ich
nicht intelligente waffen also trump hat
die wachen die sind intelligenter als er
angeblich mit meiner ist auch keine
kunst ist mittlerweile jedes luftgewehr
ja aber die frage funktioniert denn wenn
die waffen wirklich so intelligent wären
müssten sie eigentlich nach hinten
losgehen
wo siehst du den menschen dennoch vorne
wo siehst du den menschen nach vorne was
können wir besser als die künstliche
intelligenz
ich glaube da haben wir noch für ein
paar jahre vorsprung
aber ich freue mich zb auf die auf dem
pflegeroboter also ich meine ist auch
garantiert besser als jetzt
zugekaufte pflege azubi hat er dann beim
bettenmachen immer in die schnabeltasse
ab also dann programmier ich den auf
pflegestufe 5
also 5 sterne dann ist ein wöchentlicher
unterboten pflege da wird man wird da
kann ich denen die geschichten erzählen
von krieg in dem ich nie war also und
irgendwann irgendwann noch nicht jetzt
aber bald können die maschinen ja auch
selbstständig entscheiden wenn die reben
märgen geht es ihr nicht mehr viel zu
pflegen dann naja dann klemmt der
pflegeroboter das kopfkissen eben mal
nicht unseren kopf sondern oben drauf so
also intelligente maschinen die die die
schalten sich auch selber ab und andere
und du sprichst es an wir reden hier
über völlig neue ethische fragen das
gilt ja auch für das selbst fahrende
auto die programmier ich das selbst
fahrende auto für notsituationen also
wenn die frage lautet über fahre ich
selbst fahrendes auto
jetzt sind passagier den den den
fußgänger der gerade auf die straße
tritt oder gefährde ich meinen meinen
autoinsassen was was macht man da also
ich hoffe dass das auto so intelligent
ist das ist beide erwischt also ja ja
nur das wäre gerecht denn nach mit
welchen parametern soll es denn
ausschließen so wie vielleicht nach dem
äußeren noch mal aussehen
ich meine da hätten wir als erstes eine
radkappe im gebiss also schwer
wonach tolles handel das künstliche
licht
mitmachen alten nach dem alter geht ja
auch nicht oder oder nach dem geschlecht
einem für mich sind beide geschlechter
mittlerweile fast gleichwertig so aber
das auto ist er glaube ich schon ein
ziel intelligenter als man denkt ja denn
ich habe jetzt tatsächlich von meinem
auto eine eine e mail bekommt da stand
drin
der akku ladezustand ist im kritischen
bereich das war ein winter also so kalt
war
nein da habe ich zurück gewählt kümmer
dich hat aber nichts gebracht
deutschland leidet auf dem weg zur
industrie 4.0 unter fachkräftemangel
liest man ein problem ist wir haben viel
zu wenig junge frauen die
ingenieurwissenschaften studieren oder
maschinenbau die sogenannten mint fächer
wie können wir dazu bringen das zu
machen
das ist so ein bisschen die letzte
männliche domäne das technische studium
also so also samen stau und karohemd ich
bin maschinenbaustudent ich glaube das
ist für die intelligente frau zu langsam
wie
die moderne intelligente frau die will
sich verwirklichen die die wieder sie
selbst sein die wir barfuß tanzen im
regen so dann müsste man dann glaube ich
studiengängen zusammenlegen so
maschinenbau und yoga so was zum
beispiel ja und es gibt ja aber außerdem
frauen die physik studieren und was
passiert dann eine teure ausbildung
hoffnungsvolle karriere dann werfen sie
alles weg und wir eine bundeskanzlerin
und natürlich sind die eltern dann
enttäuscht
[Applaus]